all right so
count four
some points though
the form they form
is about good form it's not about
doing the set
it's about doing each move correctly
so an analogy would be
it's closer to figure skating than it is
to speed skating
it's not important how fast you get the
damn form done
it's how well you do it and key here
is the foot maneuver so you can micro
drill
the form is a drill we can micro drill
the form so the foot maneuver is we
we have videos on it we have the
umiyashi video
and in the uh tenkai video
which is you're just doing that over and
over so
take the foot change the ground vector
go to the young phase turn your body on
that single pivot point
and you're just doing that over and over
so the micro drill for the form
which is serry sensei used to do is
imagine a line
or use a line slide across
shift your weight turn pull the foot
across
and you're just doing that repeatedly
same thing don't turn the foot
the foot goes straight or you can test
yourself even more and the foot goes out
foot goes out and you turn straight
burn straight turn
that is basically the eight counts of
okay
second point
the form like anything
can be done badly so
one way is you're not doing that foot
maneuver
second way is
it's not martial it's not authentic it
has no
organizational integrity so
you're kind of just going like this
take that ski for example
it's it's like a massage it might as
well be
okay so we've done things to test
for it
i please hold on the end if i do
nothing the weapon comes back at me
you see the ski has to go forward
and through and project
it is projecting because i'm ground
vectoring
it's not projecting because i'm using my
momentum
and throwing myself do you get it
so doing
making this person move like that
is as bad a form as that
there's no coq projection
okay and again you you don't need the
base
i just need the ground vector and you
can get it going yeah i just bounced off
it
here we go here we go
okay so when i do the form now
when i go back it doesn't have to be
so staccato either so
drop and then
you get it so the first mistake is
you're slurring your speech too much
the second one is you're talking like a
robot
okay
keep the form but keep it dynamic
but don't race okay so i do each move
every time do the around
too long too long a pause it's going to
keep going
okay i'm kind of like that cadence
it's very similar to showman subaru
too fast
too slow okay
i find that you slurring your words your
pace
is too fast because you're not ground
vectoring
and i find you're too staccato your pace
is too slow
because you're not ground venturing okay
got it all right
here we go count four
i'm going to turn
so i have to shift
turn insert
shift shift
so looking at it
yawn
that's not just walking
you're doing the same drill turn
shift enter
turn
shift
shift shift boom
shift into the turn shift shift
shift
then
boom
okay i'm gonna show you again the
incorrect form
with the double pivot my line of gravity
is about here between my two feet
so i double pivot
move
the pivot block
okay come here
this is the drill for you're gonna be on
the bathroom
grip
okay then we're going to do the other
way
he's got a good grip go to shift
shift and turn
shift got a good grip shift ground move
shift ground and move
here we go again shift
turn whole body turns on
shift ground
boom move got a good grip shift
turn okay let's try you
got a lot of slack in the game that will
help you take out the slack
okay and you do the drill
[Music]
life okay the first time so
i'm gonna shift i'm not gonna step
i'm gonna shift and turn
then i had him pull because i want you
to see
that you can't walk normal you'll have
to shift your weight
and engage the front foot okay
but when we go dynamically
the centrifugal energy is pulling him
back
see so that's what's testing my
shifting there i don't want you to wait
for it to get off
and then you do the review okay
the technique's not like that so i shift
the wall okay
tristan
lighter weight right
bigger movement okay
but i'm not letting the energy off
okay now
my drill is testing my those foot
maneuvers
okay
okay let's try so that's what i'm doing
on the move
okay let's try halfway done advice
um
the grip is like your stance work
oh my feet are moving all over the place
i don't have the right body organization
if i have to keep stumbling
i was pushing on the hook and then who
can push back on me
that's not aikido so
if my grip has to open
and close i'm not blending with the
weapon
okay my grip is very relaxed
to get that adhesion not death gripping
it
not opening it moving it all over the
place so
if you if you do weird things with the
sword like i go i'm trying to
do this you can see it gets weird on my
wrist there's a lot of tension in there
hold the weapon where it's comfortable
and that's the angle for the cuts
you don't need to keep opening your
grips and closing your grips over it's
telling you something
you're fighting the weapon okay
next point there is someone getting in
it
and this is a cool cue development
but not if you finish it cut early
okay this has to come
down to my center and i have to task
myself without letting the
tip drop the tip drops because there's
no percussiveness at the bottom of that
coccu
exercise so you're just swinging the
sword
or you're stopping it
it's gonna drop boom and there's gonna
be a flex
when my hand hits
the bottom
hits so it hits the tsuka and it stops
the tip from dropping because the tsuka
can't come up
and you'll see little shakes in the
weapon
don't fake the shakes you see that hand
was moving up and down
but the sword wants to rotate in the cup
it wants to rotate in the cut
and so the tsuka wants to lift then it
hits that
mass
[Music]
and that doesn't change in the technique
i'm moving around
same thing not i move around
finish the cut
no
okay so the cut will finish parallel
the suka won't come up and it
hits my tantan at the tsuka level
okay not up here
and maybe i get a little
reverb going okay let's try two halfway
points
so the breathing
how do i get to the bottom so at this
point i'm letting everything relax
otherwise i can't flex
if everything is flexed there's no flex
at the bottom everything has to relax
so everything is relaxed and i do this
too
not just with my musculature
but also with my breath so you open
release your throat
that's flex it's flexing tartan
flex the entire time
so same thing brown
next thing i
again it's just
change the vector rotate
single point pivot this is the form this
is the form
that's all we're doing so my tendency
is as i come around
home
you can if you want you come around
and steps that's not really the form
it's just another step you did and now
you're gonna start the
technique again okay
so because the form of the is this foot
pattern
okay so you do what you want but my
recommendation is
uh here
in the form okay definitely what i would
not recommend
is uh
so when i come around here and i go that
was at least
this is again
midfoot or mid-stance balance
do you see that so you
did your ski you come around and then
this foot goes back out no
you sure you need me
into the front foot again do you see
that
the one i prefer this shirt
okay let's try it okay so if this always
happens like
uh both of you uh the form gets
it's just mushy
there's no boom okay so uh
he he's just gonna be like my uh
my target i'm gonna come back
see on every move keeps moving you just
give me different
different wide say so different bodies
do you see every every part of the
technique is doing that
okay so um
the second one it's not like uh
this stuff i bounce off i'm
i'm i'm all very solid
okay but whatever the the move is
i'm very soft on every time that i'm
cutting
okay so same exact thing
he's just grabbing okay same exact thing
grab hold hold it hold it
i'm always just moving you can't do
stuff to me hold the sword
hold the bulkhead right it's not loose
it just keeps moving can you see that
difference
right okay so um
let's see let's have one of our lower
try it's here
my pressure's gonna help you that's it
okay
do your cut strongly
finish the cut right good
then the skis sit through push
there you go up okay and then
you're going to turn feel my pressure go
shift your weight forward and turn
strongly
feel that you see see how
you got to get rid of that ability to
twist here
you move as a unit i'm going to lighten
it just to bring consciousness to it
okay
you're going to push this hand you're
going to pull this hat
go you're gonna go this way
yes yes that's it bring that foot back
good there you go okay and now we're
gonna try going forward
don't put that foot back good
and strong body push forward
push good okay and then you're going to
lift the sword up
against my grip lift from
that's here good and then you're going
to
drop it down from like this there you go
okay
i'm going to take away those body cues
and you do whatever set you want to do
step back go forward 10 con doesn't mind
and he got loose again can you see that
it's just swishing and swaying of the
shoulders and the hip line okay so
you have to imagine on your own my
hands there so for example you're going
to step
forward and when i hold your shoulders
you have to hold this part so that it
doesn't do this to you
you get it okay so shift your weight
forward
do you see how it did that you gotta
lock it
shift more you see how it's breaking
right here can you guys see that
okay lock this don't let me bend your
back
there you go okay
don't let me do that to you then
walk forward that's it you're doing it
more more more you see it's bending
okay so as you do the form you have to
be able to
do this internally through your own
discipline don't just do the cuts
we don't care about the cuts okay
remember the form assumes good form
all right let's try